crise alimentaire exploitation des
populations des pays du sud
déforestation et augmentation de l'effet
de serre samedi dernier dans les locaux
de la maison de l'environnement
l'association artisans du monde
souhaitait alerter sur les dangers liés
au développement des agrocarburants
industriels à travers la pétition la fin
pour un plein un milliard d'êtres
humains qui souffrent de la faim alors
qu' il y aurait de quoi selon les études
de la fao y aurait de quoi nourrir toute
la planète donc est vraiment des
dysfonctionnements au niveau du commerce
international au niveau des politiques
agricoles et non c'est tout ça qu'on
essaye de sensibiliser de faire
comprendre aux gens des terres agricoles
confisqué qui ne servent plus à nourrir
les populations mais bien à faire rouler
nos voitures sur les panneaux et phrases
chocs accompagne l'exposition pour mieux
réveiller les consciences
je suis sensible au problème de la faim
dans le monde
et puis quand je vois ces inégalités
criantes entre les populations du nord
du sud le gaspillage qui peut la voir
l'exploitation des pays du sud
je sais me révolte et j'aimerais bien
que tout le monde est cette sensibilité
plus en plus importante la faire pousser
des céréales ou des choses pour
simplement l'essence des voitures sur ça
mais et puis que les peuples meurent de
faim derrière ça hallucinant
j'ai vu ça sur internet je me suis dit
je veux y aller absolument pour signer
la pétition pense qu'il faut
sensibiliser et ça que c'est bien de
voir ce genre de manifestation a donné 2
d'exposition
je pense que ça peut être ça va dans le
bon sens
mais je compte d'ailleurs je signe cette
pétition samedi dernier douze signatures
ont été récoltées
la pétition restent ouvertes à la maison
de l'environnement sur internet et dans
les boutiques d'artisans du monde
jusqu'au 30 novembre